right-hander jt brubacher getting the
call for pittsburgh three wins four
losses
4.20 the era
and leading off it is rymel tapia and
first pitch put in play
that's nice perfect play to start off
the game right there again uh commanding
the fastball early earnings zone strikes
and i get an easy ground ball to start
this game off exactly what we need right
about this time
here's garrett hampson
brubaker the 27 year old from
springfield ohio
yes he did
didn't even need the appeal brown
o'norrah
paid no attention to michael perez
asking for help from the first base
umpire the home plate dump rings them up
and now the rockies have two men aboard
with two outs the inning continues for
charlie blackmon
and the o1 pitch and a swing and a liner
caught at third defoe a step and a half
to his right
oh and that saved a run thank goodness
he was there so a hit and a walk two
were left and now the pirates come to
bat in the bottom of the first it's the
rockies nothing and the pirates coming
on right-hander john gray for the
rockies start number eleven four wins
four losses 3.43 the earned run average
he'll start it off with adam frazier
who's having a wonderful month of may
gray
down into count and one john fires and a
breaking balls hit into the air into
right field easy chance for charlie
blackmon to put it away
reynolds sitting at
292 five homer's
19 rbis
2-2 again
and hit towards the left side but shaded
near the line perfectly tapia is there
to make the catch back to first goes
gamel two down here in the pittsburgh
first in this scoreless game craig
getting a
chance to play with colin moran on the
injured list he has
played including today 14 ball games
233 on 10 for 43. he does have a homer
and a couple of rbis
pitch
swaying and a miss got him with a
breaking ball
john gray strands a pair with a punch
out scoreless ball game after an inning
rainy coldy windy day here on the north
shore i'm robin smitkowski will craig
obviously everybody saw the play that
happened on thursday but one of the most
encouraging things in the aftermath of
that according to will craig when he met
with the media was the call he received
from manager derek shelton i felt really
encouraged by that for him to kind of
reach out to me to make sure that like
you know that wasn't a good good mind
space because he knows how
much pride i take into my defense
and how much i really care about and i
care i want to win and obviously that
play was you know a freak play um but he
just wanted to make sure that like you
know moving from moving forward moving
on from this that you know i'm with he
goes hey we got your back we're behind
you we know how hard you work on how
much you care bucks on the pond men at
the corners nobody out here comes
michael perez let's see what happens on
3-1 here and he swings and grounds it
hard through the middle base a nice job
for michael perez
he'll drive in defoe and the pirates
lead one nothing
oh that one just that was shot through
the infield yeah
it definitely is uh
looking much better at the plate
nowadays
pirates with a run in they're up one
nothing in the second inning base is
full for frasier who leads the league
hitting 407 with runners in scoring
position
gray ahead o2 the pitch frazier grounds
it hard to first krone will elect to go
into second draws rogers off the bag he
touches the bag the out is recorded
on the force on brubacher the run scores
tucker is in perez to third it's an rbi
fielder's choice
and the pirates lead two-nothing camel
walked last inning one of three walks
issued by john gray
one two is sky to left tapia was
guarding the line and drifts back now
and he will make the catch perez will
come in to score tapia with a good arm
throw right at the bag at second that
was an awesome throw now sac fly for
gamel
and his second rbi the pirates now lead
three nothing here in a second john gray
rocky's pitcher now the one-two a swing
and a miss perfectly placed down in
front one out second strikeout for
brubacher garrett hampson now where's
number one
batting with two outs of the base is
empty 2-2 strike three call so the
inning comes to an end and brubacher has
sent down seven in a row
here's will craig
and then craig hits one hard the
opposite way to right that's gonna bang
off that wall
blackman picks it up and craig is in at
second base with a hard-hit double off
the clemente wall yeah
six seven feet from getting a home run
opposite field shot you don't have to
hit too far it's only 320. and the
pirates have a runner in scoring
position with one out that'll bring up
the switch hitter wilmer defoe
john holding the glove at the belt now
comes the play swing and a miss breaking
ball down and gray gets the strikeout
that's number two for john and it's out
number two here in the third
so here's cole tucker
gray set at the belt
3-2 pitch swung on hit down the lit to
left and that'll be tapia who's there to
make the play
and john gray strands craig at second
base three innings complete mcmahon has
an average
exit velocity of 92.7 miles an hour
that's the fourth highest in the
national
league concentrate on the job at hand
and there you go as a strikeout for
brubacher yeah went with the curveball
right there again just the mix right
there something that he hadn't seen a
lot of here is connor joe who's in the
big leagues with the rockies familiar
name to pirate fans
wow brubaker with a six pitch inning two
flyouts so far one to left one to center
for brian reynolds
and hits this drive deep to right field
and you can clear the deck and anchor
down
ryan reynolds has homer now in
back-to-back games and that gives the
pirates a five-nothing lead in the fifth
home run number six pirates leading at
five to nothing will craig
he doubled off the clemente wall the
other way in the third by the way we saw
colin moran out running the bases
earlier today he's been out
with the
groin injury
it's allowed craig an opportunity a
little dribbler off the end of the bat
now how about that everybody's thinking
what we're thinking the fans here
if craig had backpedaled toward home
plate
from cool to coal chad cool cole tucker
runner goes from first and it's bounced
to the right side and the runner breaks
a little bit late look like safe
polanco scores despite
the late start
[Applause]
two outs and jt brubacher the
pitcher will be the eighth man to bat in
the inning he has walked and been called
out on strikes and he'll swing and hit
it sharply knocked down by fuentes and
he just got to the bag
ahead of defoe for the force out at
third
here's brendan rodgers he's grounded out
twice base is loaded two outs for
colorado
2-0 is hit to right but right at polanco
he makes the catch and the inning ends
brubacher with six scoreless innings
hearts have been at the corners with one
out for gregory polanco who hit a triple
off the clemente wally's last step up
here's the pitch and a swing and a high
fly ball out to center
hampson back still going back now with
his heels on the track he'll make the
catch that'll be a sac fly as frazier
scores easily and polanco gets the job
done his first rbi of the day and the
pirates lead seven to nothing
so one out and jonathan
game two of this double header
mitch keller
against the lefty austin gomber and a
diving stop made there's one
and holding off on the throw as
dazzy got toward the back quickly but a
nice play by frazier now
comes down to tapia and one out left to
get
struck him out looking raised the jolly
roger in game one
ryan reynolds helps lead the offense
the shutout of the rockies and the
pirates reach
their wins total from last season all of
last
year and they snap a six-game losing
streak